If you want to hear the details about Carrie's
life that weren't included in the movies,
then stick around to the end of this
video. This video is sponsored by Audible.
I've covered a lot characters in Stephen
King's universe of stories here on this show,
so in this week's episode I'm taking
it back to the one that started it all.
Welcome to Horror History, my name
is Professor CZsWorld and in today's
lesson I'm joined by my TA, The Amagi, as
we cover the entire life of Carrie White.
Carrie was created by the then rookie author
as a sort of combination of two girls from his
childhood. The first was in grade school with
King, and she was made fun of by some of the
other classmates for wearing the same clothes
to school every day. The other lived in his
neighborhood with her mother, and one time
the mother hired him to move some furniture,
and when he went inside her realized they
were crazy religious. Neither one of them
would live to read Carrie though, one was personally responsible while the other had problems with seizures.
Their fates may tie in to what ends
up happening to Carrie, but before we
can get there, I'm gonna take it alllll the
way back to the conception of Carrie White.
Margaret Brigham and Ralph White were married on
March 23rd, 1962 and that same year they first
engaged in what Margaret would refer to as 'a
sinful act', so she made she made her husband
promise never to do it again. She fell down
one day and lost the baby. And
she assumed that this was their punishment for their
sins, that God did not want her to have the baby.
One night Ralph started giving her that look
again. I’m not gonna do it right here on camera,
cause I don’t want to be a
father, but she sent him away,
and when he came back she smelled the
scent of roadhouse whiskey on his breath.
Nine months later, on September 21st 1963 she gave
birth to Carrietta N White,
Margaret’s mental state
deteriorated throughout the
pregnancy, and she planned
to kill Carrie with a knife upon birth,
because she believed her daughter would be a
carrier of the devil, but when it came time,
she could not bring herself to do it, instead
using the knife to cut the umbilical cord.
She would try again three years later in 1966.
Here’s what went down. Mrs. White had long feuded
with her neighbors, the Horan family because their
daughter, Estelle would sometimes sunbathe in
the backyard, which was within Margaret’s line of
sight. Mrs. Horan found this complaint ridiculous,
and in retaliation bought Estelle a new
bikini and encouraged her to use it whenever
she liked. So 3-year-old Carrie wandered over to a
sunbathing Estelle one day and posed the question.
“What are thoooooose?!”
I'm sorry, that was too easy not to
do. When Estelle explained the
concept of breasts to her, Carrie
wished that she could get them too,
because her mother had taught her that good
girls don’t get them as part of her wacko
religious beliefs. Estelle tried to explain the
truth to Carrie, but not before Margaret came out
and started screaming at her, to the point that
Estelle started to get into it with Margaret.
Mrs. White was clawing at herself, grinning and
drooling in what she saw as punishing herself
to make up for what Carrie had seen. This kind
of self destructive behaviour warped Carrie’s
mind from a very young age and caused
her to have an imbalance in her brain
as she grew older.
She drags Carrie into the house and forces
her daughter to go into the closet to pray,
which Carrie strongly disliked because the
religious imagery scared her. So she did what any
kid would do and threw a fit. However Carrie White
was not like any other kid. She was born with a
special gene that researchers would later refer to
as the TK gene. TK was an acronym for telekinesis,
the ability to move objects at a distance via the
use of mental power. Both of Carrie’s parents had
this gene, but it was recessive in her
mother, so it only showed up in Carrie.
Carrie’s grandmother was also
supposedly a firestarter,
an ability that would later be
explored more in another Stephen King novel,
but it’s not known if the gene for
this is the same as the gene for TK.
The neighbor, Estelle, heard Carrie’s
screams emanating from inside thehouse,
and this is what set Carrie’s telekinesis
off. It started when a huge chunk
of ice was pulled down and thumped
against the White’s roof. Then it
was several chunks of ice, and keep in mind,
this is happening in the middle of August.
The ice stopped and Margaret started screaming
again. That’s when the White’s kitchen table went
crashing out the window, a small sample of the
magnitude of Carrie’s power. She brought down a
rain of stones upon the house. Neighbors watched
as they burst through the roof shingles, punching
holes through the ceiling. The stones consisted
of chunks of granite which only came down on the
White’s property. The stones that didn’t hit
the house left small craters in the backyard.
The event became known by the
neighborhood as The Rain of Stones,
and I think it’s no mistake that it was
triggered by Carrie finding out about
the pubescent development of breasts and her
mother punishing her for it. Carrie’s powers
would be fully unleashed when she herself
reaches the age of her budding adulthood,
so there seems to be a comparison going on between
sexual awakening and telekinetic awakening.
It wouldn’t be the last time Stephen
King would make a similar comparison,
as you know if you’ve seen my Horror
History on Beverly Marsh from It.
It seems that Carrie started going
to public school in first grade,
this may have coincided with her Mom getting
a job at the Blue-Ribbon Laundry when the
insurance money from Ralph’s death had run
out. Carrie is described as a chunky girl
with pimples. None of the movies hold true
to this description, probably because her
beauty is supposed to blossom by the time
of the prom… and you can do that in a book,
but in a movie your best bet it to just hide
her looks until the prom scene comes around.
Carrie did not get along well in school though and
quickly became a social outcast. This
was mostly due to her psycho mother and
the fact that she was forbidden from taking
part in most social activities. She also
had a few particularly nasty classmates,
like Christine Hargensen and Helen Shyres.
In grade school Carrie went to a Christian Youth
Camp where they would short-sheet her bed,
hide her underwear, put a snake in her shoe,
“There’s a snake in my boot.”
...and pass around a love letter addressed
to Flash Bobby Pickett that they’d found in
Carrie’s possession. If you’re wondering who
Flash Bobby Pickett is… I don’t know where
the name “Flash” comes from, that seems to
be exclusive to Carrie... but Bobby Pickett
is the guy who wrote the Monster Mash. If
you’re wondering what the Monster Mash is,
it was a graveyard smash. And if you’re
wondering how it became a graveyard smash,
it caught on in a flash. Ohhhh kay
maybe that’s where “Flash” came from.
Carrie had to be brought home from camp a week
early. On her first day of grammar school,
she was laughed at for praying at
lunch. As you can probably imagine,
the torture from the other kids and the abuse
from her devil-paranoid mother would continue,
as Carrie moved onto the next lair of
hell commonly known as middle school.
There is a lot you can learn here on Horror
History, but if you really want the full
Stephen King experience, you gotta check out the
novel. There are so many characters, interviews
and snippets from articles from within the world of
Carrie that you’re missing out on if you don’t.
The best way to enjoy Stephen King’s Carrie
is with Audible. The audiobook is narrated
by Sissy Spacek, the actress who plays Carrie
White in the original movie. How cool is that?
Audible is
a great option for that person you
care about, or for yourself. Now is
the best time to do it with a special
offer of 53% off your first 3 months.
Access an unbeatable selection of
audiobooks including best sellers,
mysteries, thrillers, and of course: horror!
You can choose 3 titles every month:
1 audiobook and 2 exclusive Audible
Originals you can’t hear anywhere else.
Listen on any device, anytime, anywhere with
the Audible app. It’s great while commuting,
at the gym, or during your holiday travels.
With Audible, you’ll also
enjoy easy audiobook exchanges,
and your own audiobook library you
keep forever – even if you cancel.
Right now, for a limited time, you
can get 3 months of Audible for
just $6.95 a month. That’s more
than half off the regular price.
Give yourself the gift of listening. For
more - go to audible dot com slash CZsWorld.
One of the few activities that Carrie White was
allowed to partake in were these biking trips.
Actually, it doesn’t seem
like she really wanted to go,
but maybe it was a church activity or something.
In school, a boy named Billy Preston put
peanut butter in her hair. Now according
to Rhett and Link he was actually doing her
a favor, but the deep seeded rage continued
to build inside of her. People would pinch
her, stick out legs to trip her in class,
knock books from her desk and tuck
obscene messages into her bag.
In high school, Chris Hargensen prank called
her, asking if she knew how to spell “pig poop”,
and spelling K-A-R-R-I-E, which I have to say
is not even that good of a prank call… but
I guess this was before iconic masterpieces
like “Arnold Schwarzenegger prank calls
travel agency and keeps asking
about the guy they lobotomized”.
“May I have your email address please?”
“Yeah. What do you mean, we?”
“In order to book this, may I
have your email address please?”
“What about the guy you
lobotomized. Did he get a refund?”
“What guy?”
*laughter*
I can't...
Carrie would haveto endure cruel punishments that she did not
deserve, like being locked in the closet for
an entire day after stealing a 49 cent plastic
ring, and another time when her Mom found a
picture of Flash Bobby Picket under her pillow.
Guess she reallyyyy likes the Monster Mash….
At one point in seventh grade, she
seemed to try to call out for help
when she turned the following in as
a poetry assignment in English class:
“Jesus watches from the wall, But
his face is cold as stone, And if
he loves me As she tells me
Why do I feel so all alone?”
This is a piece about her time being locked
inside the closet by her mother, and while
the instructor did find that it seemed to cry out
to him, he did not pursue the topic any further.
But perhaps the biggest moment,
came during Carrie’s senior year
of high school. Carrie was the last to shower
after gym class in an attempt to avoid the other
girls, when she got her period. Like the Rain of
Stones when she was three, it was her mother’s
neglect to give her a proper education
due to Mrs. White’s unsound levels of
piousness that once again caused the issue.
Carrie believed that she was bleeding to
death, because she’d never learned what
a period is. Her mom didn’t teach her, and
she didn’t have any friends to learn from.
She staggered to the other girls, who were
finishing up getting changed, and they found
it hilarious, they basically saw this as the
equivalent of Arnold calling the travel agency.
“I just need an email address so I
can email you your confirmation.”
“OK. 2. 3. 5. 7. 2.,”
Ok sorry. I’m done. I’m done now. OK?
So the whole gym class started chanting “period”
and throwing tampons at her, and in her confusion,
Carrie collapsed in the corner. The gym teacher
Ms. Desjardin came in to see what the problem
was and ended up slapping Carrie in the face
to try to bring her to her senses. A lightbulb
explodes overhead, and this ties Carrie’s
outburst of anger to her telekinetic power.
Once Ms. Desjardin realized that Carrie didn’t
know what a period was, she tries to comfort
her and get the other girls away. She ended up
having to explain the concept of menstruation,
before getting Carrie cleaned up and taking
her to the office of the Assistant Principal,
Mr. Morton, where he files an accident form and
decides to give Carrie the rest of the day off.
Mr. Morton repeatedly calls her Cassie instead of
Carrie one too many times, and she snaps at him.
“That's not my name!” she screamed suddenly.
Morton recoiled, and Miss Desjardin jumped
as if struck from behind. The heavy
ceramic ashtray on Morton's desk (it
was Rodin's Thinker with his head turned
into a receptacle for cigarette butts)
suddenly toppled to the rug, as if to
take cover from the force of her scream.
Butts and flakes of Morton's pipe tobacco
scattered on the pale-green nylon rug.”
Like the lightbulb, this is another example of the
fervor of her telekinesis matching the anger pent
up inside of her, and with years and years of
bullying and being laughed at, she had a lot of
anger on hand to dish out pretty much at will,
which we see shortly after as she walked home.
At this point,
Carrie is fed up after having endured 17
years of harassment. There’s only so much a
person can take, so it’s understandable that
her thoughts would turn dark. But what
makes this scary is what happens next.
A five yearold boy riding his bike on the street makes
fun of her and calls her Creepy Carrie,
"Creepy Carrie, Creepy Carrie!"
so that little ****er get air
yeeted right off that bike.
Carrie would also try to use her TK
to break a window on the way home,
but she’s only able to make it wobble, showing
that she’s yet to fully master the ability. She
still has to practice more before being able
to fully channel her rage at will, but later
that afternoon she was able to crack her mirror
while self-loathing about her own reflection.
Her mother came home after getting a call from the
school. Carrie notices the fear in her mother’s
eyes. There are a few examples in the book where
Margaret seems to be able to sense Carrie’s rising
power, but it’s likely that she perceived it
as the devil inside of her daughter waking up.
Mrs. White struck her, and forced her head
into the altar they had in the living room,
commanding her to pray for her sins, to
which she insisted that she had not sinned.
This was a turning point for Carrie, because up
until now she had no reason not to believe her
mother’s lies. She was also about to graduate
high school and didn’t want to live under the
harmful hand of her mother forever, and that’s why
I think she chooses this occasion to fight back.
As Margaret tried to pull her daughter away
into the closet, Carrie refused to go quietly,
raising her voice and using
profanity against her. Again,
the fear is evident in Margaret’s eyes. Carrie
threatens to make the stones come again,
remembering the outburst that
had occured when she was three,
and her mom calls her the spawn of the devil
before dragging her and locking her in the closet.
This was probably the most she’d
ever fought back against her Mom,
but I think that's because of that rising
fear, that the punishment is not as severe
as Carrie might have thought. Carrie
even thinks that her Momma may have
been afraid she’d blow the closet door right
off its hinges if she was kept in too long.
Carrie took a little bit of time off of
school, and used it to further hone her
telekinetic abilities. She would practice
at home in her room by picking up the foot
of her bed and placing it back down. Her heart
pounded with excitement as she did so, and at
night she would dream of sending stones after
her Mom and the kids at school.
When she goes back to school, she keeps to
herself even more than usual, hoping to avoid
being the subject of laughter and gossip about
what happened, but that Thursday after her fifth
period study hall she received a surprise visit
from a boy she was attracted to, Tommy Ross.
Tommy was the boyfriend of Susan
Snell, one of the girls who had
made fun of her in the locker room,
but who was otherwise not normally
a bad person. Tommy ended up inviting
her to be his date to the Spring Ball.
This is the moment I’ve been hyping up in every
Horror History episode to date, so pay attention!
What happens next is kind of interesting.
It’s not entirely clear if Carrie is able
to shine yet. Shining is an ability in
Stephen King’s writing allowing people,
most often kids, to read minds. She’s able
to do it by the end of the story though.
Her first instinct is that Tommy is tricking
her, that he’s only inviting her to humiliate
her somehow. If she’d been able to shine,
she’d know that his invitation was genuine.
But perhaps she did shine, and saw that Tommy
didn’t want to ask Carrie to prom, which is
also true because he was only doing it to please
Sue, who felt bad about the locker room incident.
For these reasons, Carrie rejects him
at first, but he is persistent about it,
and she worries she’s going to make him
late for his next class and she accepts.
That week she goes into town and buys
some fabric to make herself a dress.
Sewing was one of the few hobbies
her Mom allowed her to have,
so she was quite familiar with the Chamberlain
Woolworth’s where she bought her material.
She had not yet broken the news to her mother,
which caused her a great deal of anxiety
and stress, which of course translated to
telekinetic energy.
On Saturday night, Carrie prepares herself
to tell her mother of the prom invite,
knowing that she is unlikely
to approve. And she doesn’t.
Ok, the tea was only lukewarm, but you get the
idea. As expected, Margaret orders her to go to
the closet, but Carrie refuses, looking to make a
statement. They get into a huge argument, because
Margaret sees this as the next step towards a
path to the devil:
MARGARET: "After the blood come the boys, like sniffing dogs. Grinning and slobbering and trying to find out where that smell comes from.
Where the smell is. That smell.
Listen, I know where they take you in their cars, I see it alright. Well you're not going."
Carrie tells her that she’s tired of being
made fun of and wants to start fitting in
with her classmates. She wants to live her
own life, not be stuck living her mother's.
Her Mom calls her a witch, and I
see that as another important step
towards Carrie’s breakdown. Even though
her mother did not treat her properly,
she was still her mother and Carrie knew no
better than to look to and love her -- not
to mention that she was one of the only
people Carrie could actually talk to.
If her mother started to oppose her, she
would have nobody to go to the next time
she is humiliated, and be forced to turn down
a darker path… and that day would soon come.
Margaret retreated upstairs and
began whispering exorcism prayers.
On May 26th, the day before the prom, Carrie
went to go talk to Tommy one more time before
the big event. She waited outside one of
his classes so she could let him know that
she’d have to be in by 11:30PM as not to
upset her mother more than she already had.
Tommy thoughtfully suggest that after the
dance they go to the Kelly Fruit to get a
root beer and a burger. He figured it would be
a good place to unwind, since many of the other
kids would be going to after parties in other
cities, and it would probably mostly be empty.
Sue would later comment on
the exchange in her book.
“This is the girl they keep calling
a monster. I want you to keep that
firmly in mind. The girl who could
be satisfied with a hamburger and
a dime root beer after her only school
dance so her momma wouldn't be worried…”
The day that Carrie would first put on the
dress would soon come. It was May 27th 1969.
As Carrie examined herself in it, the door would
swings open to reveal her mother holding a bible.
MARGARET: “Red, I might
have known it would be red.”
The red dress is symbolic of everything that
this night stands for. Prom night is the
night that high school students dress up like
adults, practice the rituals of courtship,and
in most cases do adult things afterwards. Like
paying taxes….. ok no, were talking about se--
The red dress is the perfect metaphor for that,
because it was the red blood of Carrie's first
period that made her transition into adulthood
evident. And from her Mother's point of view, as I
pointed out in my Things You Missed episode on the
1976 movie, red is also the color of the devil.
Carrie did not know if her powers came from
Satan or if they were a gift from the Lord,
but she was beginning not to care,
and would use her powers against her mom
in order to attend the prom if necessary.
Margaret asked her to burn the dress, and pray
for forgiveness with her, which of course angers
Carrie. Ironically, the dress would be one
of the few things at the prom to not burn.
Carrie uses her mind to swing the door shut
on her mother, who goes down to go to work.
That night, Mrs. White spends at least
two hours praying in their home chapel,
so Carrie is forced to pin the corsage
to the shoulder of her dress herself,
an image that is indicative of how she was
now truly alone with nobody to turn to.
As it got later, Carrie got more nervous. Thoughts
creep into her head about Tommy standing her up,
and she actually starts to think
that this would be for the best.
There would only be one more month of high school,
so the humiliation wouldn't last all that long.
But then she thinks about being
stuck with her mother forever,
about going over to the 86 year-old Mrs.
Garrison's house and watching game shows
and soap operas rather than starting her own life.
Carrie is restlessly picking up objects with
her mind and putting them back down on the
ground when she hears Tommy's car approach. her
mother's chanting stops as hearings the buzzer.
When Carrie answers the door neither
one of them says a word at first,
until she asks "do you like me?" And
he replies with, "you're beautiful."
With that, the two set off together,
not knowing that this would be
the final evening of their lives.
When Tommy Ross pulled into the parking lot he
asked her if she was nervous, and she said yes,
but I think the next scene does a far better job
of communicating how nervous she actually was.
Everyone stopped to look at Tommy
and Carrie as they entered the prom,
creating a momentary silence that
was only broken by Tommy’s buddy
Geroge Dawson coming up and throwing
a mock insult about his appearance.
“Dawson lurched forward with his fists up,
and for a moment Carrie felt stark terror.
In her keyed-up state, she came within
an ace of picking George up and throwing
him across the lobby. Then she realized it
was an old game, often played, well-loved.”
Carrie was obviously very on edge, so
George’s date, Frieda tries to calm her
by joking that she’ll dance with Carrie if
Tommy and George kill each other. She also
asks Carrie about her dress and is very
impressed that Carrie made it herself.
As the four of them go into the dance together
George is doing Flash Bobby Picket impressions.
What is with this Flash Bobby Picket?
This is like the third time he’s come up…
When they entered, Carrie found
the dance to be glamorous,
and there’s a line where she specifically
views the long flowing dresses on the
dance floor to be like wraiths. Maybe that’s a
foreshadowing of all of their impending deaths.
As Carrie, Tommy, George and Frieda admire the
mural, Carrie knew she’d remember the moment
forever, but perhaps what she did not know, was
that “forever” would only be a few more hours.
George takes Frieda onto the dance floor
and Tommy and Carrie decide to sit down.
One of the bullies, a girl named
Norma takes them to their table,
asking about Carrie’s dress as she does so.
Norma comments on how different Carrie looks,
the one time in her life that she actually fits
in for a short while. But Carrie notices something
of a secretive look on Norma’s face, and that
makes Carrie nervous -- and for a good reason.
Norma was part of a conspiracy created by
Chris Hargensen’s clique of girls known as
the Mortimer Snerds who planned to humiliate
Carrie by getting her elected as Prom Queen,
where Hargensen would pull the cord to have a
bucket of pig’s blood dumped all over Carrie.
Tommy asked Carrie to dance, but she told him
she wanted to just sit for a while. In reality,
she had no idea how to dance and
wanted to avoid the embarrassment.
She asks Tommy to light the candles at their
table, which may be another foreshadowing,
this time about how the night would end in flames.
At 9PM that evening, Tommy asked Carrie to dance
for a third time, and she finally admitted that
she did not know how. They end up waiting for a slower
song, and that’s a scene that’s in most if not all
of the movie adaptations, but what the movies
fail to explain is that the dancing isn’t the
only thing that makes Carrie uncomfortable, she
is also bothered by the idea of going out there to
rock and roll music, which is something Carrie’s
mother has conditioned her to see as sinful.
And if that’s true I’m going straight
to the bottom layer of hell…
I probably am anyways, let's be real.
They go around to talk to some of the other
tables and Carrie sees people bringing out
the King and Queen thrones and she thinks
that they are beautiful and imagines her
and Tommy winning the crown. Maybe this
was just her imagination running wild,
because she’s obviously not going to be a popular
choice without intervention, but maybe this
was actually her ‘shining’ and seeing a little
glimpse of that future where they are victorious.
When they get back to the table, Tommy
goes to get her a little bit of punch,
and Carrie sees the gym teacher Ms. Desjardin, who
tells her about her own experience at the prom,
how she had been taller than her date, how the
corsage he’d given her had clashed with her gown,
and how the broken tailpipe on
the car made a horrible noise...
TAILPIPE: "What's up guys, it's Tana Mongeau."
...but that she still found it to
be a magical night. I only bring
this up because they’ve changed this
story in literally every adaptation…
MS. COLLINS: "I had a date with the captain of the basketball team."
He was 6 feet 7 inches tall. Anyway, we went in his pickup truck. Which of course broke down. And we had to get out and walk the last half mile to the prom."
MS. DESJARDIN: "My date brought a toy gun so he could pose like James Bond for the picture."
CARRIE: "Oh, he sounds like fun!"
MS. DESJARDIN: "Yeah. They arrested him. I didn't have anybody to dance with. Spent the entire night alone until my father picked me up."
Anyway, Carrie tells Ms. Desjardin that she
couldn’t quite tell how the prom made her feel.
Tommy comes back with the punch, and Carrie
thinks the encounter with Ms. Desjardin’s was her way of
saying she’s sorry for everything
that happened in the locker room.
At 9:30, the class president Vic Mooney,
who would be one of the few survivors of
the Black Prom, announces the opening
of the ballots for Prom King and Queen.
Carrie is surprised to see her and Tommy’s
name on the ballot, which Tommy explains
as the school voting for single candidates
and their dates getting shanghaied into it.”
Tommy suggest they vote for themselves, and
Carrie giggles. When she does so she’s surprised
at the sound of her own laughter, which is one of
those things where if you think about it, that’s
incredibly sad, because she’s never had friends,
and so never really laughed even in her entire life. And
I’m not gonna play the clip, don’t worry I’m not
gonna play the clip… but it was before this video…
So there were less reasons to laugh in the world.
While filling out the ballot, she accidentally
hurts herself as the pencil breaks in her hand.
Like the small candles, I think
the small amount of blood that
is drawn is tiny preview of the
splashdown that would soon come.
The Honors Society collects the ballots and the
students watch as two piles stack
up higher than any of the others,
and eventually it is announced that Ewen High
School has had it’s first ever tie. Sixty-three
votes for Frank Grier and Jessica MacLean and
sixty-three votes for Tommy Ross and Carrie White.
They decide to hold a run-off ballot to determine
the winner. This time, Carrie begged Tommy not to
vote for them, perhaps sensing that something was
going to go wrong, but Tommy had promised Sue to
try to give Carrie the best night possible,
so he elects to try to vote her in anyways.
It was 10:07PM when the secondary
ballots were collected, and again,
it looked like it was going to be close. Tommy and
Carrie end up winning by just one vote. Had Tommy
listened to Carrie and held back his vote, perhaps
the whole disaster could have been avoided.
OK, so I was actually curious about
what would happen if it was a tie again,
so I looked it up and found some random
school in Ohio that had their rules posted
online. They said they’d also institute a
second vote if the initial poll is tied,
and then if that one is tied,
there can be multiple winners.
Though I feel like Hargensen still
probably would have dumped the blood
just to get revenge on Carrie for
getting her in trouble at gym class.
Ushers would appear to lead Carrie
and Tommy to their thrones while the
band played the school song. When they
took their place in front of the crowd,
everything had fallen into place for Christine
Hargensen, and although she hesitates at first,
she pulls the cord, which turns through the
pulley and attaches to the two buckets of
blood sitting on the rafters above
the Prom King and Queen thrones.
After the massive red splash came down, Carrie
looked like she’d been dipped in red paint.
For a moment, the gymnasium was completely silent.
The two buckets clanged together and one of
them came down and hit Tommy in the head.
“And the winner, by split
decision is.... THE BUCKET!”
Someone started to laugh at the noise the
bucket made when it knocked out Tommy,
but it wasn’t until Carrie
opened her eyes back up,
the only part of her that was not red,
that everyone started to crack up,
but they’d soon find out that Carrie White
would be the one to have the last laught.
Ms. Desjardin ran up to her aid, and
although she was not laughing on the
surface, Carrie could hear the giggling
reverberate through the gym teacher’s head,
so she uses her TK to push her aside
where she goes crashing into the wall.
Carrie ran through the crowd, where someone
tripped her; she crawled away and ran out of the
gym, out of the lobby, down the stairs and outside
of the school. With the laughter behind her now,
she got her feet tangled and fell into the grass.
The whole thing had only been about two minutes.
She was filled with tears, and her first instinct
was to return home to her mother in shame.
And had Mrs. White treated her daughter better,
that may have been the end it. But then again,
if that had been the case, probably
none of this would have happened.
Carrie thinks about the closet, about how
long she would be locked in it this time.
About what her mother would do to her. And
that is what made her snap. Just as she
did to little Tommy Urpter on the bicycle,
Carrie decided to use her powers for evil.
She ditches her shoes and walks barefoot back to
the lobby, and all at once she slams the doors
shut. The screams she heard from inside were
described as being like sweet soul music. The
panicked crowd stampedes towards the doors,
where Carrie stares back at them through the
window. People battered against the doors which
did not budge. Some went out the back fire doors,
and Carrie allowed them to escape, thinking
she’ll have time to pick them off later.
She uses her mind to turn on the overhead
sprinklers, and when everyone was soaking wet,
Carrie could not hear them crying, so she
decided that the sprinklers were not enough.
He pulled out the power cables into the puddles
of water that now covered the gym floor,
causing a huge flash of light and the
electrocution of one of the performers
holding onto a microphone stand. After another
flash of light, his shirt had caught fire and
one of the main power switches backstage
exploded. Light cables writhed in the air,
and one of them came down into the
water, causing yet another violent flash.
Carrie went back down the stairs, all while
holding the main doors closed with her mind.
With the entire gym on fire now, she made her
way onto the street. The town fire whistle
sounded and I think this is what caused her to
momentarily lose her hold on the doors, but she
quickly regained it and slammed them back shut,
catching someone’s fingers inside as she did so.
The movies always seem to under
appreciate the damage that Carrie
did to the town after leaving the
high school for the last time.
She headed into town and had the realization that
the fire department may put out her creation,
so she telekinetically twisted the fire
hydrant lugnuts, perhaps the most mentally
draining use her power yet, based on how it
is described. She’s able to open the valves
and water bursts everywhere. Carrie’s heartbeat
speeds up as she realizes she’s essentially won.
The gushing water is a symbol that connects
the shower scene where Carrie was hurt and
humiliated to the rampage scene, where Carrie
pays that back to the entire town of Chamberlain.
She goes to the grass plaza, where she’s seen
trying to rub her hands clean on the side of her
dress, and she opens a few more fire hydrants up
before heading to the gas station, Teddy’s Amaco.
She got there just before 11
o’clock, and she removed all
of the nozzles and made them
pour gas onto the ground,
until someone unknowingly dropped a cigarette.
This caused a massive oil tank explosion,
which killed one off the police officers on
duty that night who happened to be nearby.
Shortly after, at 11:12PM, Carrie had the
entirety of Main St. in flames. Her next
target was the other gas station in town,
Tony’s Citgo, which exploded at 11:15. The
blast was so big that it temporarily lit up all
of Summer Street in what looked like daylight.
This was followed by another secondary explosion.
Her progress was slowed a little bit but not
halted when she stepped on a broken bottle
in the street.
This was a small reminder that she is human,
despite her terrifying powers, and she too
could be hurt and bleed just like anyone else,
something that would soon come into play.
She arrives at her next destination at 12:06AM
on the morning of the 28th, where she’s able to
use her mind to locate and open the gas main
underneath Jackson Street. Shortly after,
she’s seen going inside the Carlin Street
Church. This is purely speculation, but I think
she had hoped to find the answer to one of the
last questions that had eluded her to this point:
was she really an agent of the devil, or were
her powers a gift from God? When she received
no answer, she used a whirlwind of psychic
energy to destroy the inside of the church.
She emerged from there at 12:11 and
telekinetically swings the doors shut
behind her. She also took out power
transformers and dangled live wires
onto the street.
One of these cables even reached a
nearby house and set that on fire
as well. And remember that gas valve she
opened on Jackson Street? Well at 12:17,
an ambulance attendant pitched a cigarette
butt out the window and set that ablaze too.
See, if the regular dangers of smoking were
not enough to deter you, take Chamberlaine,
Maine in 1979 as an example. The damage
could have basically been cut in half if
people weren’t lighting up. And this guy
was an ambulance attendant. He’s literally
supposed to keep people healthy,
why does he even have a cigarette?
It was not long after that when Prom turned into
Homecoming, because Carrie found herself back at
the door of the small house on Carlin Street. The
lights were entirely shut off when she arrived,
the only illumination coming from the
raging fires approaching from the town.
Objects fell from the walls as she
got close, and when she arrived,
she blew the all of the living room windows
outward and slammed the kitchen door.
Carrie is described to this point to have
completely lost touch with her humanity,
but being back in the presence of her mother may
have brought her back down to earth a little bit -- either
that or she was starting to realize the severity
of what she had done -- because when she stepped
into the house she was trembling and whispering
out for her Momma. Her dress was in tatters.
Like the poem she handed in back in seventh grade,
her return home had a deeper meaning then
what was there on the surface, but the mother
and daughter were both so mentally unhinged
that there was only one inevitable outcome.
When the two confront each other,
Margaret hides the kitchen knife that she’s
spent the last several hours sharpening…
Yeah calm down Margaret. She tells the story of
Carrie’s conception and the pregnancy, how she
planned to slay the devil inside of her when
Carrie was born, which drives her crazy -- she
channels her telekinetic anger into the plates
in the kitchen which they both hear exploding.
Carrie was unable to follow
through with what she planned to do to
her mother at first, and begged for help.
I think many people would argue that Carrie was
not a monster, but rather a victim of her own
circumstances, and if there is any evidence
of that, this part is probably an example.
Margaret asks her to pray with her one
more time, but when Carrie bows her head,
Margaret brings the knife down over her.
Carrie seems to sense this at the last moment,
and mentally moves the trajectory of the knife.
"Mom!!!!"
The way Carrie kills her mom has got to be one of
the coolest uses of telekinesis that
I’ve seen anywhere, she tells her:
“I'm going to give you a present, Momma.”
Then she looks into her chest and slowly
brings her mother’s beating heart to a stop.
I just think that’s so metal, because
there’s basically nothing you can do
to defend yourself against that.
Carrie could not stick around long,
because the flames from the fires in
town had spread as close as next door,
and the roof, which she had already destroyed onetime
14 years ago with stones, was starting to ignite.
Carrie slipped out the back door.
She crosses through backyards and when she can
no longer walk she crawls up an embankment,
not stopping until 1:15AM when she arrived
at a roadhouse known as The Cavalier.
TOMMY: "A bunch of people were going to The Cavalier after."
It’s even suggested in the text that this could
be the same roadhouse where Ralph White had
stopped the night Carrie was conceived, and
she’d crawled all of this way to destroy it.
But her main motive, most likely, had
more to do with who was at The Cavalier:
Chris Hargensen and her boyfriend Billy Nolan who
had helped set up the buckets of blood. They had
just heard about the disaster and gotten in
the car to flee, and when Billy turns on the
headlights, Chris screams because Carrie White
is standing there with a crazed look on her face.
Instinctively, Billy just floors it, and as
they approach, they hear the words “Carrie,
Carrie, Carrie” being chanted
in their heads over and over.
It seems that when Carrie’s sanity snapped, so
too did her ability to keep her shine inside
her own head. Much of what we know
about her rampage through the town
obviously doesn’t come from Carrie first hand,
but those who encountered her and lived to tell
the tale could hear her thoughts as if she were
no longer a radio, but now, a radio station.
It’s never spelled out for us how
this exactly works in the book,
but there is one point where Sue seems to believe
that the “zone of Carrie’s influence” was
shrinking as she was starting to die.”
If the unscrewing of the fire hydrants
wasn’t Carrie’s most impressive feat,
then what would come next definitely
is. She spun the car around in a half
circle and sent it flying into The
Cavalier. Billy is thrown through
the windshield as Chris crumbles against
the dashboard before the vehicle explodes.
That seemed to take up the rest of Carrie’s
remaining energy. She laid on her side panting,
and tried to drag herself across the parking
lot. She felt that nothing would matter,
as long as she could turn herself over and
see the stars one last time before she died,
but she did not even have the strength to do that.
The last person Carrie White
ever encounters is Sue Snell,
the one girl who tried to give Carrie
that one good high school experience
at the prom, and the one person who
actually had her best interests in mind.
Sue turned her on her back, her final
wish fulfilled, and Carrie in a moan,
asks who is there. When she finds out that it’s
Sue, Carrie accuses her of being in on the trick,
to which Sue asks her to look
inside of her and see the truth.
Carrie does so, scanning the
library of Sue’s mind. The
concept of a metaphysical library or
warehouse of memories is consistent
with some of King’s later writings
like Dreamcatcher and Doctor Sleep.
Carrie searches through all of Sue’s thoughts
and memories, but finds no evidence of a plan to
sabotage her at the prom. With that last little
peace of mind, Carrie pulls back out of Sue’s
head, but in what I can only imagine is some kind
of telekinetic equivalent of Newton’s Third Law,
Sue gets sucked into Carrie’s mind against
her will and perceives her final thoughts. She
hears Carrie crying for her mother, and her last
conscious thought is: “Momma… I’m sorry…. Where--”
before fading out into the black.
Carrietta White’s official time of death is
recorded as May 28, 1979 at 2:00AM. Carrie was
one of King’s most misunderstood characters. If
you read the book, you get a better understanding
of how Carrie was just a normal girl, but she’s
pushed into being an outcast by everyone around
her, and the idea of her telekinesis and mind
reading abilities that seemingly nobody else
has is a metaphor for her forced separation
from the rest of society. The concept would
become a staple of the author’s work,
But Stephen King has actually gone on record
saying that Brian DiPalma’s 1976 movie
adaptation of Carrie is the superior version of
the story. DiPalma brings in many more concepts,
themes and motifs in his interpretation of
the tragic tale, so we decided to do a second
video over on Amagi’s channel analysing
the life of Carrie White in the movie.
And if you like Horror History,
definitely go subscribe to his channel,
he covers the lives of many other of
your favorite characters, including
those outside of the horror genre. Remember
to ring that deathbell for notifications,
and I’ll see you over in that second
video. Assuming we both survive.